Jay Leno's brush with death as cameras  roll  no it wasn't a stunt this part stopping  accident occurred while the host was  filming a segment for his si MBC show  Jay Leno's Garage with legendary stunt  driver Bob Riggle can I go for a ride  with it absolutely let's do it  moments after the two buckled into a  hearse Hemi under glass known for its  two-wheeled tricks and top speed 2,500  horsepower  I'm two-wheeled what could go wrong the  daring drag takes an unexpected turn for  the worse and flips not once not twice  but multiple times with Leno bracing and  holding on for dear life  I like to drive anything unusual the  avid car enthusiast is no stranger to  adrenaline and known for his passion for  anything with wheels thankfully after  this terrifying moment the comedian was  able to walk away unharmed you all right  there oh yeah I'm fine it was gonna get  more exciting than that at least until  he gets home wait to my wife say is this  your wife yes